okay everybody this is my spoiler review
of the new a24 horror film talk to me
this is directed by the Filippo brothers
and it is to me by far the best horror
film of this year and I think it's
better than any Horrors from last year I
think this is the type of film I've been
desperately waiting for since we haven't
had an ariaster level of horror in a
while not even from ariaster so this
felt like an ariaster film in a lot of
ways but also had its own voice in it
and what I loved about this film is that
it has so many things set up in the
beginning that get paid off by the end
in callbacks it goes from just the first
scene here with Mia when she's with
Riley and they hit this kangaroo I love
that by the end of the film Mia is in
that same position on the road where the
kangaroo was but about that kangaroo her
not being able to put it out of its
misery sets up how she's not able to put
Riley out of his misery and she sees the
kangaroo in the hallway sees in a
reflection when she's trying to make
this Choice she just cannot do it it's
not in her DNA so what I think happened
where they left ambiguous when she has
Riley in the wheelchair and brings him
down some people think Jade pushed her
to save Riley into the street but I
think she knew the spirits were playing
her and that definitely is not really
her mom's Spirit telling her to kill
Riley and that she to me sacrificed
herself to save Riley and jumped in the
road whether it's sacrificed in the
sense of just killing herself because
she was going mad and didn't want to
hurt Riley eventually with this or that
there was something they might explain
in a future film where she actually gave
her soul up and that since fried Riley
that instead of putting a person out of
its misery by killing it you put a
person of his Misery by sacrificing
yourself that is how well I saw the
ending but that was left to be ambiguous
I thought it was brilliant how they
wrapped it up that she was on the other
side of the table in this spirit world
of these spirits of the hand I thought
that's great I love Horrors that have a
nice bow like that you think of the
witch you think of mid-summer that's
horror it's best but it also hits with
meaning and a character you really care
about and Mia and that is such props to
the actress of Sophie wild she was
incredible note for note awesome and
just a scene acting-wise it stood out to
me really well with her and also the
actor of her dad was when the dad
confessed what really happened with the
mom again I do think that was really the
dad I think that the mom that was
telling her that she didn't kill herself
was this swamp woman that was posing as
um the swamp Spirit that's the one who
was sucking Daniel's feet which was also
a wild scene and that is such an
interesting concept they did with the
spirits that made it stand out more a
lot of times in a lot of Horrors
recently the spirits are nice you know
they're friendly but these Spirits were
messed up and they were trying to
manipulate her and make her do some
pretty awful things so I really liked
how they went with that approach I also
loved in the horror aspect that they
warmed it up meaning those first couple
sequences with the hand it was like okay
this is like this fun party vibe to it
but it wasn't that scary it wasn't that
intense but it was purposeful because it
made it hit so much more when you knew
something bad was gonna happen with a
little brother and when Riley does it it
is so brutal that scene when he's
hitting his head I couldn't believe how
far went it was so disturbing and that
continues on really every scene with
Riley when he's in the hospital and
hitting the back of his head and even
when Mia gets a vision of worry stuck in
the spirit world with all these spirits
that was really disturbing imagery so I
really like that they had warmed it up
and that it wasn't afraid to go there
but it was earned and it was emotionally
intense to watch happening with Riley
character they did develop time with in
the beginning and it worked on
relationships too they made it
interesting in relationships your
relationships with her Daniel and Jade
in this kind of dramatic but not too
dramatic love triangle but also the
relationship she had with Riley and
looking out for him and protecting him
and I think it was very important to see
where she was talking to Riley at the
end of the night and how much she loved
Riley that's what makes me think she
sacrificed herself for him and I think
that it was important that scene because
she talks about she had a nightmare
where she didn't see her reflection in
the mirror which we'll see in the final
sequence when she is in this like
Purgatory going the superior world after
she has died and it makes you wonder if
she had psychic abilities and that
wasn't a nightmare just like the
original owner of the hand was a psychic
so I think that's really interesting I
love that they Twisted it there too or
you knew the spirits were bad because
they made her accidentally kill her real
dad it was always tricking you in a good
way and not a cheaty way and I thought
the whole time I was really on the edge
of my seat and it still had really
effective heart but it was more
disturbing hard than like scary horror
it's just disturbing and it worked and
the only eye roll I had in the film
writing wise was when we find out that
the two who originally had the hand
failed to mention everybody else that
the guy who had the hand originally
killed himself and stabbed his brother
they left that part out of the whole
thing and that someone could still be
possessed after they play so I wasn't
crazy about that and honestly I don't
even think you need to have that plot
line or that character of the brother
because it was just like okay she talks
him on the bus for a second but you
could have left that maybe explained in
a future sequel so I didn't even think
it was necessary to this story to even
know that I I just think that was kind
of silly it really didn't add anything
to necessary plot for the story we were
watching and being mostly in Mia's shoes
so that's the only problem I have with
it but otherwise I thought this was a
great horror film it's going to be tough
to top this one I think it's my favorite
horror in the past three years so I am
very impressed this is the philippo
brothers debut as a directorial feature
so really really well done I'm gonna
give this film a solid nine let me know
what you thought down below I love to
hear your thoughts I read every comment
I try to respond as many as I can please
make sure to subscribe it helps me in so
many ways you have no idea so if you do
that right now that would be so awesome
so competitive out there so I can
appreciate all the support I can get and
I'll see you next time